it is almost a daily occurrence as
Moscow steps up its aerial bombardment
of Ukrainian towns and cities
this time the strike was during daylight
hours it was the middle of the morning
when a barrage of missiles rained down
on the capital
these images show terrified children
running through the streets looking for
cover
all of the Rockets were shot down but
Falling fragments caused a number of
casualties
a piece of debris fell near my house I
thought I had dropped something then I
saw on our house group chat that
something fell near to our house I went
out to look and there was a fragment of
a rocket lying there
for the frightened residence it means
hunkering down Underground when the air
raid siren sounds
I heard two or three explosions and then
I heard five or seven more explosions
that's when I realized something
terrible was happening I read the
telegram channels and thought it'd be
best to go to the subway after all
there have been at least 15 attacks this
month alone mostly at night officials
claim Russia is changing its tactics to
try to evade Ukraine's air defense
systems they know that we have improved
our capacity a lot and right now they're
trying different tactics to have us
um fire all our missiles to have us
um show where the locations of them air
defense systems are and of course to
take down the morale of the people the
intensity of Russia's raids is
increasing ahead of Ukraine's
anticipated counter-offensive
people here are expecting more attacks
in the coming days
Alex Rossi Sky News